Christopher Nolan films are events unto
themselves nowadays as Nolan uses every
ounce of the clout he won through his
Batman Blockbusters to make Grand scale
films that he might not otherwise get
the chance to tackle in September 2021
Nolan revealed that his next project
would be Oppenheimer a film about
legendary scientist J Robert Oppenheimer
and his work creating the first atomic
bombs Killian Murphy who worked with
Nolan on The Dark Knight trilogy and
Inception will play the Title Character
during his years in the Manhattan
Project meanwhile the film's massive
Supporting Cast will include Emily Blunt
Robert Downey Jr Matt Damon Florence
Pugh Rami Malek Benny safdi Josh
Hartnett Dane DeHaan Jack Quaid Matthew
Modine Alden ehrenreich Kenneth Branagh
David de smallchin Jason Clark and
Minnie many more Oppenheimer will blow
up the box office on July 21st 2023